hey everybody it's media and
welcome back to the channel we're
thrilled to have you here with us today
today we're diving deep into the
fascinating world of Hydroponics but not
just the basic stuff you might already
know we're talking about next level
techniques to supercharge your yields
and take your indoor garden from Zero to
Hero imagine Lush vibrant plants that
grow faster and healthier than ever
before now if you've ever grown anything
you know the struggle is real when it
comes to maximizing your yield it can be
incredibly frustrating to put in all
that effort and not see the results you
hope for too much water not enough
nutrients pests diseases it can be a
real pain these challenges can make
gardening feel like an uphill battle but
with Hydroponics we can hack the system
this Innovative method allows us to
control the growing environment
precisely we're talking bigger healthier
plants less water waste and basically
becoming the ultimate plant Whisperer
imagine having the power to grow plants
that are not only larger but also more
resilient over the next few minutes I'm
going to break down five Advanced
hydroponic techniques that are like
cheap codes for plant growth these
methods will revolutionize the way you
approach indoor gardening we'll explore
how they work why they're so effective
and the best plants to use them with
you'll gain insights that can transform
your gardening experience whether you're
a seasoned grower or just starting out
these techniques will give you the tools
to grow more food faster and with fewer
headaches no more guess work just
results so if you're ready to unlock the
secrets of hydroponic Mastery and take
your gardening game to the next level
buckle up smash that like button and
let's dive in get ready for an exciting
journey into the future of
gardening all right first up We've Got
Deep waterer culture or dwc for short
now this technique is all about giving
your plants Roots a luxurious bath in
nutrient-rich water imagine a spa day
but for your plants in a dwc system your
plants are suspended in net pots filled
with a growing medium like clay Pebbles
with their Roots dangling down into a
reservoir of aerated nutrient solution
this means the roots are constantly
submerged getting all the water and
nutrients they need whenever they need
them but here's the prle move adding an
AirStone and air pump think of it like
giving your plants a constant supply of
oxygen infused smoothies the AirStone
creates a stream of bubbles that
oxygenate the water preventing root rot
and promoting explosive root growth it's
like giving your plants a superpowered
energy drink now dwc with aeration is
particularly awesome for leafy greens
like lettuce spinach and herbs these
plants love to guzzle water and
nutrients and the constant access
provided by dwc makes them Thrive you'll
be amazed at how quickly your lettuce
heads up and your basil explodes with
flavor next up we're talking talking
about the nutrient film technique or nft
this one's all about precision and
efficiency picture a water slide but
instead of screaming kids it's a thin
film of nutrient solution flowing over
your plants roots in an nft system
plants are placed in channels or tubes
and a pump constantly circulates a
shallow stream of nutrient solution over
the roots this ensures The Roots get a
constant supply of oxygen and nutrients
without being completely submerged but
here's where things get really
futuristic automated monitor ing by
integrating iot sensors into your nft
system you can monitor pH levels
nutrient concentrations and water
temperature in real time it's like
having a team of tiny scientists
constantly checking on your plant's
well-being this data can then be sent to
your phone or computer allowing you to
make adjustments remotely and ensure
your plants are always in The Sweet Spot
for growth nft with automated monitoring
is a GameChanger for crops like
strawberries lettuce and basil these
plants love consistent moisture and
nutrients levels and the precise control
offered by nft ensures they get exactly
what they need when they need
it now let's talk about a technique
that's all about targeted efficiency
drip irrigation with Precision nutrient
delivery this Innovative method combines
The Best of Both Worlds ensuring that
your plants receive the exact amount of
water and nutrients they need precisely
when they need it this method is like
giving your plants a personalized IV
drip of Nutri nutrients tailored to
their specific requirements imagine each
plant getting its own custom blend of
nutrients delivered right to its roots
ensuring they get exactly what they need
right where they need it this Precision
not only promotes healthier growth but
also maximizes the efficiency of
resource use in a drip irrigation system
small tubes called drip emitters are
placed at the base of each plant
delivering a slow and steady drip of
nutrient solution directly to the root
Zone this targeted delivery system
ensures that every drop counts
delivering a slow and steady drip of
nutrient solution directly to the root
Zone this method is incredibly efficient
reducing Water waste and ensuring that
nutrients are absorbed effectively by
the plants this minimizes water waste
and prevents nutrient runoff making it
an environmentally friendly option by
conserving water and reducing the need
for chemical fertilizers drip irrigation
supports sustainable farming practices
making it an environmentally friendly
option it's a win-win for both your
garden and the planet but here's the pro
tip use an automated timer and
adjustable drippers these tools allow
you to fine-tune the system ensuring
that each plant gets the right amount of
water and nutrients at the right time
this allows you to customize the
watering schedule and nutrient
concentration for each plant based on
its specific needs with adjustable
drippers you can easily modify the flow
rate to match the growth stage of your
plants it's like having a personal
nutritionist for your garden you can
monitor and adjust the system as needed
ensuring optimal growth conditions
throughout the growing season you can
adjust the drip rate and frequency as
your plants grow adapting to their
changing needs this flexibility is key
to maintaining healthy productive plants
ensuring they always have the perfect
amount of moisture and nutrients this
method supports robust root development
and overall plant Health drip irrigation
with Precision nutrient delivery is
especially beneficial for fruiting
plants like tomatoes which require
consistent moisture and nutrient levels
to produce highquality fruits peppers
and cucumbers these plants Thrive when
they receive a steady supply of water
and nutrients which supports their
growth and fruit production these plants
need a consistent supply of water and
nutrients to support fruit development
and the targeted approach of drip
irrigation helps maximize yields and
produce flavorful juicy fruits this
method ensures that your plants are
always at their best and the targeted
approach of drip irrigation helps
maximize yields and produce flavorful
juicy fruits with this system you can
enjoy a Bountiful Harvest of delicious
nutrient-rich
produce get ready to enter the future of
farming with aeroponics this technique
is all about giving your plants Roots
the Royal Treatment suspending them in
midair and showering them with a
nutrient Rich Mist it's like something
out of a sci-fi movie in an aeroponic
system plants are suspended in a closed
chamber and their roots are periodically
sprayed with a fine mist of nutrient
solution this allows the roots to absorb
maximum oxygen leading to faster growth
rates and higher yields but here's the
secret sauce using high pressure misting
systems these systems create a super
fine Mist that coats The Roots evenly
ensuring optimal nutrient absorption
it's like giving your plants a
refreshing spa treatment every few
minutes The increased oxygen
availability also promotes beneficial
microbial activity in the root Zone
further enhancing plant health and
growth aeroponic is particularly well
suited for leafy greens strawberries and
herbs these plants thrive in highly
oxygenated environments and the constant
misting provided by aeroponics allows
them to reach their full growth
potential last but not least let's talk
about maximizing your growing space with
vertical hydroponic farming this
Innovative method is revolutionizing the
way we think about agriculture
especially in urban settings where space
is at a premium this technique is all
about thinking outside the box or rather
inside the tower by utilizing vertical
space you can grow more plants in a
smaller area making it an efficient
solution for modern farming in a
vertical hydroponic system plants are
grown in vertically stacked layers
allowing you to cultivate a lot more
food in a much smaller footprint this
method not only saves space but also
optimizes resource use such as water and
nutrients it's like turning your Gard
into a high-rise apartment building for
plants each layer can be tailored to the
specific needs of different different
crops creating a highly efficient
growing environment this method is
perfect for urban Farmers or anyone with
limited space who wants to maximize
their yields imagine having a lush
Garden in the middle of a bustling city
right in your own apartment or rooftop
but here's the pro move using smart
Lighting systems like LED grow lights
these lights are energy efficient and
can be programmed to mimic natural
sunlight ensuring your plants get the
right amount of light at the right times
these lights can be customized to
provide the optim light spectrum and
intensity for each stage of plant growth
this means you can fine-tune the
environment to suit the specific needs
of your plants promoting healthier and
faster growth it's like giving your
plants a personal Sun that follows their
every need with the ability to adjust
the light spectrum in photo period you
can create the perfect conditions for
your plants to thrive by adjusting the
light spectrum and photo period you can
encourage faster growth enhance flavor
and even influence the size and shape of
your fruits and vegetables this level of
control is what makes vertical
hydroponic farming so powerful vertical
hydroponic farming is incredibly
versatile and can be used to grow a wide
variety of crops from leafy greens to
fruiting plants the possibilities are
nearly endless but it's particularly
well suited for lettuce which grows
quickly and efficiently in these systems
herbs which benefit from the controlled
environment and cherry tomatoes which
can produce abundant yields in a compact
space
these plants thrive in controlled
environments and can be easily grown in
stacked layers making them ideal
candidates for vertical systems the
ability to control every aspect of their
growth environment means you can achieve
consistent highquality produce plus the
compact nature of vertical Farms makes
them perfect for indoor growing allowing
you to enjoy fresh homegrown produce all
year round whether you're a hobbyist or
a commercial grower vertical hydroponic
farming offers a sustainable and
efficient way to grow
food and there you have it folks five
Advanced hydroponic techniques to take
your indoor gardening to the next level
we've covered everything from deep water
culture with aeration for supercharged
root growth to Vertical hydroponic
farming with smart lighting for
maximizing yields in limited spaces
remember these techniques might seem
Advanced but with a little bit of effort
and the right information anyone can
Implement them and reap the rewards of a
bountiful hydroponic Harvest now now I
want to hear from you which of these
techniques are you most excited to try
out let me know in the comments below
and don't forget to share pictures of
your hydroponic setups and your amazing
results I love seeing what you guys are
growing and if you found this video
helpful be sure to give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
awesome hydroponic tips tricks and
tutorials until next time happy growing